[Music]
because they were such high profile
attractions at amusement parks and are
often featured in films orchestra killer
whales are one of the most familiar
forms of sea life but in the wild
they're increasingly rare for over four
decades a team of researchers has been
studying three pods of orcas in the
pacific northwest the data collected has
given an inside look at the endangered
whales family structures their behavior
even their longevity we met up with one
man who's made it his life's mission to
watch over and revive the whale
population
off the coast of port angeles in
washington state there's a team that has
whale watching down to a science
for the past 45 years ken balcom is
taken to the waters of the pacific
northwest leading the orca survey a
long-term photo identification project
focusing on what's known as the southern
resident killer whale population of
puget sound well this is where we had
our very first encounter on the 8th of
april 1976.
i saw a dorsal fin
and
they were heading west so we turned
around and went with them
at 35 years old camera in hand balcom
was working for the national marine
fisheries service and tasked with
counting how many whales were left after
the practice of capturing killer whales
from marine parks ramped up in the 1960s
and 70s a lot of people didn't think we
could find them
and then even my boss didn't think if we
found them we could tell them apart an
impossible job made possible using photo
id techniques pioneered by a canadian
marine biologist it turned balcom's
hundreds of thousands of photos into a
scientific database at that time we had
photographs 35 millimeter pictures that
was a real key
the results of the survey only about 70
orcas remained in the sound with an
astounding 40 percent of the population
having been taken into captivity or
killed during a capture attempt
balcom's findings would help end the
trade in killer whales in the pacific
northwest but the orca's man-made
problems didn't stop there in the late
1980s the whales stopped doing their
regular pattern and
basically they weren't coming to puget
sound twice a month anymore it was
fished out a depleted food supply an
issue that continues for the whales
today
which greatly inhibits their ability to
reproduce this is our indicator advance
indicator the canary and the coal mine
kind of thing if we lose the ball on
the wild
nature
humans are not going to last
very long after that in response to what
he's already witnessed balcom founded
the non-profit center for whale research
to study the whales and use their
findings to promote conservation
as we cruised along the salish sea
balcom told me that orca sightings were
a weekly occurrence in these waters
decades ago
the orcas have called this place home
for many thousands of years their
presence first documented by the native
americans but on our voyage we saw not a
single one a sad situation that balcom
is working to change
not at sea but about eight miles
upstream on the edge of olympic national
park
balcom took us off-roading for a look at
both the source of the problem and a
possible solution
this is the elwha elwha river and it's
essential to your operation
it's essential for the whale's food
right it's going to bring salmon back
to a pristine status
where there'll be lots of food for the
whales what happened to the salmon
well on this river it was dams we had a
dam about two miles south of us and no
fish past that dam for 100 years the
population of the chinook salmon went
from around 30 000 a year to almost zero
in an effort to restore the river's
ecosystem congress authorized the
removal of the elwha dam in 1992
after decades of planning the largest
dam removal in u.s history began and was
fully removed by march 2012. this river
had the biggest salmon that were in the
pacific northwest they were up to 125
pounds really huge fish and they fed a
food chain
and the whales were part of it so
now that the dams have been removed this
is starting to come back
and we want to celebrate it and
you know let the world know that that's
how you do it record recover the
ecosystem and balcom went a step further
in october of 2020 at the age of 80 and
without a job his center for whale
research purchased this 45-acre ranch
bordering both sides of the waterway
where the majority of the remaining
chinook salmon spawn
the 700 000 price tag looming over his
head and his heart until a private donor
stepped in when they called up and said
we want to pay it off
i was like
i started shaking
it was an honor
it still is
i don't have to worry about that
and your legacy
everyone's legacy it's the whales it's
the whales
yeah
it's it's it's for them oh yeah there
they go a healing process that balcom
can now check in on and record whenever
he wants
he took us to the section of the river
where the salmon spawn
doubting that we would find any action
it was to our surprise oh my gosh
they're way over there they're there you
see them yeah way over there something's
going down if it can be done balcom says
it will take 20 to 25 years to get the
salmon back to their original numbers
but for now the few fish we spotted
together are a sign of hope we're really
lucky i mean to be able to just walk up
and oh there they are that's like
walking up and
seeing the whales go by
yeah it's not quite as exciting but it's
pretty exciting
last year around seven thousand chinook
salmon were counted in this river this
is the fruit of your labor
this is it this is what i wanted to see
last year i just saw two
this year what you had eight over there
or two or three here
they're still coming by so describe what
that feeling is
uh oh this is like
they're back
where nature's coming back
it's it's just like
it's worth it
money doesn't count
this counts
you know this is
whatever it takes
what what he's been able to do has
really been compared to what jane
goodall did in her work in east africa
with the
chimpanzee and you think about it there
are only 73 orcas left in puget sound uh
it really is a testament to one man
uh having an idea and just sticking with
it and he's a guy you cheer for yeah i
mean it just comes through everything he
says about it how much he cares about it
his absolute love for it and that it
takes time it takes time